I just saw a video from a mom who her narcissistic co parent
is not allowing her to see her oldest child on his birthday
it's his weekend
so sucks to suck
WAP WAP you don't get to see the kid today
and I've been there and it does hurt
and I just wanted to give you some perspective
there's you know
there's three pieces to this conflict that's going on
the other parent
the child and you
the other parent is doing this just to hurt you
there's no consideration for the child whatsoever
cause obviously
a child is gonna want all the people they love to be present at big events
so this has everything to do with you and nothing to do with the child
whatever big Celebration or whatever the fuck he did for the kid
that is not for the kid
that is to try to rub shit in your face
the reason he's doing it is to fucking hurt you
to ruin your day
to make you cry
so you know what I started to
to started to do instead
on my children's birthday
I celebrate me
if they're not with me
I gave birth
that was a big fucking day for me too
and I'm gonna
I'm gonna have cake on my kid's birthday
I I always do this
if I don't have them on their birthday
I buy a cake
and I celebrate them myself
I celebrate myself for having the child
and I celebrate my child
and I make sure to save a piece of that cake when they come home
and then we have their birthday cake together
and the kids know what's going on
they fully understand
cause they probably ask
is mom gonna be here
and when dad looks him in the face and says no
or whatever bullshit
they are go like
you're an adult
you were able to look back on your childhood
and shake out what was true what wasn't
who was a dick who wasn't
your kid is gonna do the same
so don't give the ex the satisfaction of having it ruin your day
fuck you you know what
I gave birth today
and you know what
on that birthday
I was so fucking tired and exhausted when I gave birth to my kid
I'm happy to have a day to celebrate myself
make myself feel good
and when I see my baby
they're gonna be happy to see mommy anyway
we're gonna celebrate
he's not taking anything from you
he's being a petty little prick
and in the end
you will win
so in the meantime
just know that uh
you did the right thing
he's just trying to punish you
and just don't accept that punishment I love you